RETO MEIER: Hello, and welcome
to the App Clinic.
My name is Reto Meier, and I'm
the tech lead on the Android
Developer Relations team.
And today I'll be designing the
ultimate Cricket tracking
app for Android.
If you're wondering why I'm
not joined by my usual
co-host, Ian Ni-Lewis, well,
despite 4 hours of
excruciating training, Ian still
can't reliably determine
an LBW decision without
referencing both
Hot Spot and Hawkeye.
And even then, half the time,
he'll forget to check the
pitched outside leg.
So rather than subject came to
the written examination on the
Duckworth-Lewis method, I've
decided to host today's App
Clinic solo.
Now, I'm the sort of person
who considers Pictionary a
torture roughly in line
with water boarding.
So the focus of my design will
center on architecture.
I'll be using apps that let you
follow cricket scores to
provide some context.
But the same techniques and
approaches will work just as
well for a range of apps,
particularly other sports like
baseball or any code of
football, whether that's
throwing, kicking, catching
a round or any
other shaped ball.
Now fair warning, I took many
of these screen shots during
day two and three of the second
Ashes test, so any
members of the Australian test
squad suffering from PTSD
should look away.
As engineers, it can be tempting
to start designing
our apps in terms of the data
we have access to, then
considering how to display
that data.
Instead of building the ultimate
hammer and then
packaging it in a shiny box,
invest some time examining the
problem as a user without
considering how you'd go about
solving it.
So let's take a look at the
problems the existing apps
already solve.
Cricinfo is celebrating its 20th
anniversary this year,
and they've always been
my go-to site for
following the cricket.
What I really like about their
mobile app is that the info
you're most likely to want--
live match scores--
is front and center.
Swiping left and right allows
you to move between all
different currently-live
matches.
Beyond that, everything else--
fixtures, news, video, et
cetera-- are all within
easy reach directly
from the front page.
Cricbuzz takes a similar
approach to live scores, but
has limited the front page
to a list view of
current news articles.
The other content is still
available, but they've moved
off the main UI and into this
navigation spinner.
Now, I actually prefer this
approach in general, as it
makes the app landing page
a little less cluttered.
So in terms of solving problems,
we can see that both
apps are providing live scores,
upcoming fixtures,
cricket news, photo galleries,
and access to the rich world
of cricket statistics.
In terms of priorities,
the focus of both
apps is live scores.
So let's dive in here
a little deeper.
When you select a live match in
Cricinfo, you're shown the
standard score summary.
It shows the current inning
score, the batsman, bowler,
and even the last few balls
from the current
and previous innings.
Below all of that, we
have our commentary.
Now, like the landing page,
everything is available by
interacting directly
with the UI.
You can swipe or click these
icons to move between the
summary score, full score,
commentary and news views.
Clicking on a particular player
will take at their
stats page.
This is really the heart of the
app, and they've done a
great job of fitting a lot of
information into a small area.
Cricbuzz has a very similar
matched score display, but its
moved the navigation into
the overflow menu.
They've also incorporated
a couple
of really cool features.
Specifically, they've got score
tracking and live audio
commentary.
Now, I actually think audio
commentary is a big enough
feature that it deserves
promotion right
to the action bar.
Now, note that both
of these apps have
used a refresh button.
Now, a big part of my
architectural redesign is
going to talk about how to
eliminate the refresh button
from apps like this.
Things like every refresh button
are a great example of
how implementation can sometimes
drive visual design.
As engineers, we need a way to
call the method that initiates
the downloads.
And then you add a visual
control who's event handler
will trigger that
method, right?
Well, no.
If you start with your idealized
visual design, you
wouldn't include a
refresh button.
You'd just make sure that the
scores were always up-to-date.
Much like a save button,
why would I ever not
want to save my work?
Now, just because you have a
save method doesn't mean you
need to have a save
control on screen.
And it's the same thing
with refresh.
Now I never start a project
without sketching out my UI.
And I can't draw for
sh-- love or money.
But this is really an important
place to start.
By defining the user experience
early, you add
useful constraints around what
your app needs to do and how
it needs to do it.
That clarity is what lets you
build something that's
targeted to solving real
problems, rather than a
collection of features you
built because you could.
Now I took those raw sketches
and used the design guidelines
to try and put together some
mocks that sort of had that
simple and consistent feel
in line with the
Android visual language.
In addition to the two apps that
we just looked at, I also
took some inspiration from the
ABCs cricket site, which is a
really clean design without
being too spartan.
So I've really tried to sort of
merge those philosophies.
Now, I'm clearly no designer,
but for today's app clinic,
I've at least taken my pencil
sketches and turned them into
some primitive mocks
for us to look at.
For the real deal, the Android
design and action team are
going to transform them
into real mocks
for next week's show.
So this is the first
of the mocks.
I think it's important to
remember that a lot of
developers can get lost in the
weeds of potential, of what
their app could do.
So we get so caught up in what
we think we might be able to
build in the long term that we
lose sight of why we built the
app in the first place.
So my guiding principle for
software design, both visual
and architectural, is to focus
on the simplest way of
providing the most important
information.
And I do that by asking
why has someone
downloaded this app?
And the easiest way of answering
that question is to
ask it yourself.
Why would I downloaded
this app?
Now for me, it was to track the
scores of the Ashes test.
So, like Cricinfo and Cricbuzz,
when you open the
app, you get the live scores
for all of the ongoing
matches, front and center.
And you can swipe to transition
between them.
For the remaining space, I was
tossing up between displaying
either just all kinds of news
or upcoming fixtures.
And to make a choice, I tried to
imagine the user experience
based on someone's intention
when opening app for the first
time when downloading.
Or even once it's installed,
every time that
they open the app.
Now if you're checking for an
upcoming match, that takes
exactly however long it takes
for you to find the match that
you're trying to look for.
That's a fixed time cost that's
entirely dependent on
my implementation on how long
it takes for you to get to
that point within the app.
Now if you open they app to read
cricket news, the time
cost is variable.
And it's dependent on how much
time the user wants to spend
reading the news.
So the time taken to navigate
to news is really only an
incremental additional time cost
on top of the time that
they were already planning
to spend reading.
So by displaying fixtures, we're
removing time from a
critical path of one of those
user interactions.
Now, for navigation to other
features, I've actually gone
with a sliding drawer.
Mainly because it's the new
hotness, but also because I
think it's a really elegant
solution to navigating around
a lot of heterogeneous
content.
Now this is the case for an app
like this, where you have
a lot of different features
which could theoretically each
be separate apps.
But they've been bundled
together for convenience or
because they're thematically
similar.
So a navigation drawer, a
sliding drawer, is a really
neat way of being able
to have that sort of
meta layer on top.
Now really, all of this is
window dressing for the real
money, the live match display.
Now, following the same
principles of focus, I've
tried to keep the match activity
as simple as I can.
You land on this score summary,
where I've used
country flags to add a little
bit of visceral reaction,
something that only a
national flag seems
to be able to invoke.
Now, the commentary is
immediately below.
And the whole thing is
just a vertical--
vertically scrolling
list view.
Now, you can do swiping
horizontally, and that will
switch between the summary view,
the full score view, or
related news based
on that match.
So we've got a two-dimensional
scroll, which will let you do
the change the content that
you're displaying or the
content within that view.
Same as the other two apps we
looked at, clicking on a
particular player will take you
to their stats page and
clicking on a country will take
you a country page, which
is going to include stats,
recent results,
and upcoming fixtures.
Now, any sport that includes
five-match series that last
five days each is going to
produce a lot of statistics.
And any sport that includes an
afternoon tea break is going
to give you a lot of
opportunities to delve into
those stats.
Now, in this tablet mock up,
I've tried to give an idea of
the sort of space you've
got available when
optimizing for tablets.
Now, to me, it seems obvious
that you're going to want to
drop a summary and other list
views over here on the
left-hand side.
And then you've got almost 2/3
of the remaining display space
as prime real estate to do
things like commentary, player
stats, not to mention even more
detailed things, like
match statistics, player versus
player breakdowns, a
multitude of graphs, and of
course, even the possibility
of adding things like Hawkeye
directly within the tablet
experience.
Now, the mobile phone app is an
ideal way to keep track of
a series or a match, but done
the right way, a tablet app
actually introduces the
opportunity to deliver a true
cricket companion that gives
you an immersive experience
that's richer and more easily
accessible than the
information already
available web.
And we already know that
users spend more
time in apps on tablets.
So creating a rich tablet
experience is a great
opportunity to drive that
deeper user engagement.
Now the last feature I want to
talk about from my visual mock
ups is starring a match.
Now, starring is a pretty
well-understood metaphor in
Android that's generally
associated with bookmarking
something or marking something
as important.
Now, within my app, I'm going
to take it as an explicit
signal that the user is
interested in this match.
And as an implicit signal that
she might be interested in one
of more of the teams or even
the location with match is
being played.
Now, we can use this
information
in a number of ways.
First, by adding a shortcut to
starred matches directly from
our navigation drawer, but
also as a way of enabling
notifications for
match events.
Now, by default, I'm going to
trigger a notification for
every heart-breaking wicket,
every change of innings, and
every merciful stumps
for every match
that has been starred.
And I will include a flag within
the settings menu to
let users de-select any of those
particular match events.
Now, the notification itself
should show everything related
to that event, so the inning
score, the wicket details, and
when you expand the
notification, the commentary
associated.
Ideally, you shouldn't have to
click on the notification to
enter the app to be able to
understand the full context
around the event that
has triggered it.
There's a range of actions that
you can associate with
each notification, anything from
links to the video clip
to sharing the data or even an
option to cancel further
notifications for the remainder
of the game when it
all just becomes
too depressing.
Now, the real trick is making
sure that these notifications
are timely but don't
drain the battery.
And that's really the
underlining philosophy of my
entire design.
Moving beyond the visual design,
we need to create an
information architecture
that will let us bring
these mocks to life.
Now, we need to consider
three factors in
our software design.
What do we need to show?
When do we need to update
what we're showing?
And how do we perform these
updates efficiently?
Now fundamentally, the
answers to those
questions are pretty simple.
Show users what they're
expecting to see.
Do updates as often as you need
to, but don't do updates
if they're not necessary.
And perform them using a
combination of Google Cloud
Messaging, sync adapters,
and the volley library.
And of course, you want to do
all of that in a way that
makes it look as though it's
happening by magic.
Now, I'll forgive you for
thinking that those answers
are a little simplistic.
Certainly, I understand that a
simple design can look very
different once you've
implemented
it in the real world.
So before we dive in, let's take
a look at a few simple
techniques we can use to add
a little bit off magic.
We're going to do that by
offering some features which I
think users will appreciate but
probably weren't expecting.
Now, when we looked at Cricbuzz,
I mentioned that
they're live commentary option
is a big enough deal that it
should get promoted to the
action bar directly, but what
if you don't have access
to a live audio stream?
Fear not.
You can take advantage of
Android's text-to-speech
library to create your own
dynamic commentary.
This is a massive features for
folks like me, who want to
follow a match while I'm driving
to and from work.
In fact, you can take this a
step further and include an
option to automatically trigger
dynamic commentary
when the user is driving using
the new location-based
services activity
detection APIs.
But of course, the real magic
comes for an app that seems to
have been built especially
for you.
And that means showing
you exactly what
you expect to see.
Now, when you open the app to
the landing page, there's
likely to be several cricket
matches being played,
including tests, one-dayers,
Twenty20, domestic and
international.
So how do you make sure that the
match I downloaded the app
to track is the first one
displayed in this list?
Now at I/O last year, I talked a
lot about context and taking
advantage of what your phone
knows about you to create a
personalized experience that
will make your app feel as
though it was custom built
for each of your users.
So how do we find out what match
each user wants to watch
without asking them first?
Well, for a start, we can assume
that the teams involved
in a starred match are likely
to be of interest.
Similarly, we can keep track
of which matches
the user has watched.
Over time, we should be able to
see a pattern to understand
which teams or which grounds
the user is interested
in the games of.
But that doesn't help
us the first time
that the app is opened.
For that we need to be a
little bit sneakier.
So let's start with
the most obvious.
Check where they are using
location-based services.
Request the course location
information and then reverse
geocode they're last-known
location to figure out which
country they're in.
You can even go a step further
and figure out which state or
province they're in to
understand which domestic site
that they're likely
interested in.
But I live in the US,
so that's really
not going to work.
So what else can we try?
Well, another good signal is the
locale that the device is
configured to.
It's a strong signal, but my
device doesn't let me choose
an Australian locale.
Well, if I asked you what the
score was on the cricket,
you'd assume I was interested in
Australia and it's not just
because I'm a masochist, but
because I have an unmistakable
Aussie accent.
Now, it turns out that the
Android voice recognition lets
you select your accent as
well as your language.
So using this code, you can see
which language variation
has been selected.
Boom, now you can use my accent
as a way to guess which
country I support.
And suddenly you've got the
opportunity to customize the
UI for me and put the Aussie
matches right at
the top of the list.
Now, this might seem like a
lot of work for a fairly
trivial modification.
But now, the first time I open
your app, there's a very good
chance that I'll be presented
with the exact match that I
downloaded this app in order
to find out the score for.
That's a really powerful,
positive signal that I've done
the right thing, that I've
downloaded the right app, that
the person who developed it is
on the same wavelength as me.
Other ways we can find out what
people are interested in.
We can take advantage of
Google+ integration.
So we can use the explicitly and
implicitly tracked teams
from our friends to help inform
the app of the matches
that we are likely to
be interested in.
And as a bonus, by using Google+
sign in, you can now
synchronize those starred
matches across all of the
user's devices.
So, now we know the matches that
you're user has indicated
that they're definitely
interested in and the ones
that they are likely to
be interested in.
So how else can we use that
data to improve the
performance and usability
of our app?
Well, we could start by sending
it all to your server.
Now, this is an important step,
as it's going to help us
is ensure that we only perform
updates as often as needed to
ensure that we can eliminate
the refresh button.
Now, that means that the data
being displayed needs to be
constantly up-to-date.
And for sports scores, that
means getting updates as soon
as they happen, but without
wasting bandwidth and battery
requesting updates in
between overs or
during the drinks break.
Now, updates are going to fall
into two broad categories,
background and foreground.
When the app is open and the
user is looking at it, they're
either going to be browsing,
looking at news, stats,
upcoming fixtures, and so on.
Or they're going to be watching
a match as it happens.
Now, in the latter case, you
should be looking to implement
the best practices for creating
apps that transfer
the data in battery-efficient
ways, so that when they're
browsing around your site,
they're not draining the
battery every time they
click a link.
Now, I like to call this
the big cookie
model of data transfers.
In real terms, that means
minimizing the number of radio
state transitions caused by your
app transmitting data.
To do that, you need to
pre-fetch enough data so as to
prevent additional downloads,
usually within the next two to
five minutes, without just
cheating by downloading
everything on your server.
Now typically, that's going
to look like around
five megs of data.
Now, what you download is
whatever you think the user is
likely to request within that
next five-minute time window.
It's another good opportunity
to use those implicitly
tracked teams to pre-fetch
commentary from matches that
they're likely to observe or
which news stories they're
likely to read.
Pre-fetched data is available
instantly and has zero
incremental cost in terms
of battery life.
So it's generally good
practice to be pretty
aggressive with what you choose
to pull down ahead of
time, while all the time being
conscious of the associated
bandwidth cost.
When we do need transfer data,
you want to batch all of your
transfers together.
It's more efficient to transfer
a lot of data at once
rather than spreading
it out over time.
So if you need to pull down
commentary for new match, you
should take that as an
opportunity to preempt your
next batch of pre-fetch news
stories and score updates.
The easiest way to do this is
by bundling all of your
transfers together within
a sync adapter.
Then within each of these
methods, you can make a more
fine-grain choice regarding what
data you actually want to
transfer each time a sync
adapter is called.
Now, for example, fixtures.
You probably don't need to be
updating them more than once a
day, whereas news headlines will
more likely want to be
much more frequent.
Now, when it comes to real-time
updates, there's a
temptation to set up a timer
that just pings your server
for an update every minute
while your app is in the
foreground.
Certainly, that's an approach
that I took years ago, back in
the days of Google desktop.
Before I knew better, I wrote
myself a widget that tracked
scores on Cricinfo
by scraping a
particular page every minute.
It was perfect.
While the match was ongoing,
I got those constant
bowl-by-bowl updates.
Unfortunately, it had a bug
that included a race
condition, which, when
triggered, meant that the
widget missed the
end of a match.
So it would get a 404 but would
keep pinging the site
over and over, every minute of
every hour of every day.
It was only brought to my
attention when the company's
tech ops folks wondered why I
was downloading one and a
quarter gig of data every
week for a month
while I was on holiday.
So regular updates, foreground
or background, need to be
carefully managed.
In fact, foreground updates are
really just a special case
of background updates, one
which happens much more
frequently.
So let's take a look at how
they can work together.
And we'll start by taking a
closer look at the background
update case.
Now, we have starred updates
for which we want
notifications.
We have implicitly tracked teams
for which we want to do
regular updates to keep the
app fresh, and updates on
fixtures and stats that probably
only need to happen
once a day.
You may even argue that only
starred matches need to be
updated in the background, but
personally, I think that
there's value in keeping the app
up-to-date even when it's
not running, as long as we can
do so in a way that doesn't
drain the battery.
If you do it right, you minimize
latency at start up.
You can make sure that the app
is still useful even if you
don't have connectivity right
when you open it.
So, like the visual design, I
start my update architecture
with pen and paper.
Now, this design translates
into this flow chart.
So let's step through it.
And we'll start with our
starred matches.
Now, these are the games our
users have explicitly marked
as important and for whom we're
delivering notifications
while that app is in
the background.
Now, matches that of being
observed while in the
foreground, for which we want
to have those real-time
updates, they fit into
the same category.
For those updates, both the
foreground and background
case, we're going to
rely entirely on
Google Cloud Messaging.
We'll set a flag on the server
to decide whether we want to
have every bowl updates or if
we just want significant
events like wickets
or end of innings.
But rather than just sending a
push message notifying the
client of impending update, we
can just send the entire
update within the GCM payload.
Now, every GCM message can
contain up to 4K of data.
One over's worth
of commentary's
typically around 1K.
So you can safely send the
commentary for each bowl of an
observed match or the details of
a fallen wicket, including
the commentary, for background
notifications.
Now, the result is a
significantly decreased
latency for those updates and
a simpler, more efficient
update implementation where
you're not having to figure
out how to modify the timing
of your update based on the
current state of the match.
And you never doing updates
more frequently
than you need to.
Now, for matches that we aren't
actively tracking, we
can use Google Cloud Messaging
to tickle the client when
there are updates related to the
teams we implicitly track.
We do want to initiate an update
for every new news
update or new fixture or new
match for teams we aren't
actively tracking.
So we can prioritize
pre-fetching information
related to the teams we
think are the most
relevant to our users.
Now, given that the data is
changing on the server, it
again makes sense for these
updates to be driven from the
server side using GCM.
But we can make them even more
efficient by having the client
influence the frequency with
which we actually receive
these updates.
Now, I like to implement a usage
back off pattern backed
by a sync adapter.
So every time we perform a
redundant update, defined as
two updates that happen in
between the app being closed
and being reopened, we double
the amount of time that we
wait before we performed the
next background update.
Now, that same approach will
work either by changing the
frequency of a periodic sync
set for sync adapter or by
setting a flag on the service
to each of those client
updates to say how frequently
we should be
performing this tickles.
The update itself will be formed
by triggering a sync
adapter in exactly the same way
as it should happen when
the app is opened.
And you want to get that
fresh data when
the user starts browsing.
Now alternatively, or
additionally, you can use
further context to modify the
background updates and
browsing pre-fetch rates
of your application.
For example, a user standing
still, browsing the app, is
much more likely to browse
for longer than one
who is walking around.
So you can use activity
detection to increase
pre-fetch amount, or the
frequency of prefetches, based
on the fact that they're
standing still.
Similarly, you can use the
tilting activity to determine
when to initiate daily updates,
like fixture changes,
every morning when you user
picks up their device rather
than specifying an
arbitrary time.
Finally, there's one more piece
of magic that we can
build which sits at the
confluence of background
updates and implicitly tracked
teams, series notifications.
So by tracking the teams that we
think users are interested
in, we can send them infrequent
notifications to
alert them of significant
events related to
a particular team.
This can be a really effective
way to help drive engagement
by reminding people
to use your app.
But it's important to be very
careful not to become spammy.
I'd recommend only sending
notifications once per series.
It would be great to know that
the Ashes is about to begin,
but I don't necessarily want to
be told every single match
that Australia is playing.
Now, it may even make sense
to add a "stop these
notifications" action to the
notification itself.
Or go the other way, and perhaps
include an action to
star every match
in that series.
So they get one prompt and are
then able to opt in or opt out
of getting further
notifications.
So we've covered all the
technologies already.
But let's quickly review the
technologies that we should be
using to perform all
of these updates.
Now, I'm not going to go into
too much detail because I've
already been talking for
a very long time.
But I'll share some the
resources that you can use to
find out how to implement what
I've been talking about.
So everything in this design
is driven from your server,
with Google Cloud Messaging
either transmitting the data
directly or initiating a sync
adapter update through
tickling the client.
The Google Cloud Messaging APIs
are described in detail
at developers.andro
id.com/google/gcm and you can
find out lots of detail on
implementing sync adapters in
this new Android training class
on transferring data
using sync adapters.
For populating list views,
particularly useful for things
like news, you can use volley,
which you can find out all
about from Ficus Kirkpatrick's
awesome IO talk from
earlier this year.
One of the challenges of
having server-generated
notifications based on matches
that you're syncing across
multiple devices is avoiding
spending your users with the
same notifications on their
phone and on their tablet.
Or if you're someone like me,
on four of their phones and
seven of their tablets.
Now, one of the great new
features in Google Cloud
Messaging is user notifications
are just part of
the upstream messaging API.
It's available through
Google Play services.
Now, this API lets you send a
message to other instances of
your application.
So if you dismiss a notification
on one device,
you're able to send a
notification to the client
running on every device that
that notification is no longer
relevant and it will
disappear.
This is something you can see
in the latest version of
Google Calendar.
You can find our more details
from Francesca Nerieri's IO
talk from earlier this year,
where he went into a lot of
detail and Google Cloud
Messaging and how you can use
it within your app.
That was a lot of information
to digest in a relatively
short period of time.
I hope you enjoyed this slightly
different take on the
App Clinic.
As always, we'd love to hear
your thoughts and feedback.
In the meantime, I'll leave
you with these key points.
The refresh button is dead.
Google Cloud Messaging allows
you to eliminate all
unnecessary transfers
while maintaining
those low latency updates.
The transfers themselves should
all be handled by the
sync adapter, which is not
only efficient, but also
handles things like connectivity
changes to make
sure your transfers always
get through.
Context, anything from your
users' location to their
accent can help provide those
magical touches that will
cause people to fall in
love with your apps.
And if you're an Australian
cricket fan, it's probably
best to avoid installing any
these apps for at least the
next six to 12 months.
Thank you for joining us this
week on the App Clinic.
Check out developers.googl
e.com/live/android or the
Android Dev YouTube channel
to find out more about our
upcoming episodes of this and
other Android developer shows.
My name is Reto Meier.